lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
platicarles un poco acerca del dinero y
las tasas de interés y lo voy a intentar
hacer en un sentido bastante amigable
para entender la macroeconomía porque si
realmente entendemos lo que quiere decir
la oferta de dinero y la demanda de
dinero y más aún el precio del dinero
que he dicho a otras palabras no es más
que la tasa de interés
si logramos entender todos estos
términos entonces va a ser mucho más
fácil que nos comuniquemos con fluidez
acerca de todo esto y sobre todo el
contexto macroeconómico y bueno casi
siempre lo que más expectación causa
cuando se habla de la palabra dinero en
macroeconomía es pensar en cuál es el
precio del dinero y el precio del dinero
es ni más ni menos que la tasa de
interés y es que básicamente lo que
quiero que pienses no es que vas a
comprar dinero sino la tasa de interés
habla acerca de una renta del dinero si
lo que queremos saber por ejemplo no sé
es cuánto cuesta un departamento en esta
zona y bueno voy a pensar en la zona en
la que yo vivo es decir cerca
california si yo quiero rentar un
departamento entonces la renta este
departamento está cerca de 1200 pesos
mil 200 pesos por mes lo que es 14 mil
400 pesos por año 14 mil 400 pesos por
este departamento por todo el año por
vivir aquí todo el año es decir eso es
lo que te cuesta rentar este
departamento
ahora bien vamos a pensarlo desde la
otra perspectiva supongamos que yo voy
al banco y le pido prestado 10 mil pesos
para no sé dar el enganche de un
automóvil pagar mi renta qué sé yo el
banco seguramente me va a decir bueno te
presto este dinero pero con una
condición tú vas a tener que pagar una
cierta tasa de interés y vamos a suponer
que esta tasa de interés es del 5% y ese
interés no es otra cosa más que una
renta sobre el dinero que te están
prestando qué quiere decir esto que te
van a cobrar de interés cinco centavos
por cada peso que te van a prestar cinco
centavos por cada peso
por año esta sería una tasa de interés
anual haber otra vez otra vez otra vez
otra vez si restamos un departamento
entonces vamos a pagar 14 mil 400 pesos
por el departamento en un año mientras
que si nosotros pedimos dinero prestado
al banco a una cierta tasa de interés
del 5% anual entonces vamos a pagar 5
centavos por cada uno de los pesos que
nos van a prestar por año este que
tenemos aquí es entonces lo que
conocemos como la renta en el dinero y
si ya me entendiste esto ya podemos
pasar al siguiente paso en el cual yo
quiero graficar la curva de la demanda
del dinero la curva de la oferta del
dinero y además hablar todo esto en un
sentido de macroeconomía y ya con esto
puedes entender entonces a qué me
refiero cuando hablo del precio del
dinero y bueno para ahorrarnos un poco
todos los demás cálculos que se hacen al
respecto vamos a pensar que estamos
hablando de un modelo simple es decir no
es un modelo complejo con personas que
pueden pagar o no pagar dinero o con un
cierto riesgo o con una cierta
probabilidad de que cambio la tasa de
interés qué sé yo mejor vamos a suponer
que todos
van a comprometerse a pagar este dinero
y lo van a pagar por lo tanto no hay
riesgo no hay probabilidad de que
algunos fallen todo está en orden
entonces voy a bautizar esta gráfica
como el mercado para prestarte dinero
durante un año y si lo sabes o no te lo
cuento de una vez las tasas de interés
van a depender de la cantidad de tiempo
que tú necesites el dinero no es la
misma tasa de interés y yo te presto
linera durante un año o si te lo presto
durante un mes y esto es debido a que
hay más riesgos y yo te lo presto en un
año a ti te puede pasar algo con lo cual
no pagues la deuda y entonces yo
perdería mi dinero por lo tanto como
existe un cierto riesgo mayor entonces
la tasa de interés es distinta si yo te
lo presto durante un año a durante un
mes y siempre que vemos gráficas acerca
de la curva de la oferta es la demanda
en el eje vertical tenemos al precio
pero como estamos hablando del precio
del dinero pues entonces en este eje
vamos a tener la tasa de interés y
entonces vamos a suponer que este es el
30% de la tasa de interés este de quien
medio va a ser el 15% por lo tanto aquí
vamos a tener el 10% del 5% del 20% y el
25% y en el eje horizontal vamos a tener
la cantidad del dinero y bueno la cual
va a estar dada no sé en miles de
millones de pesos así que vamos a
suponer que es un préstamo no sea un
país oa un estado oa una persona con
mucho dinero no lo sé o tal vez al mundo
entero le vamos a prestar dinero por lo
tanto aquí vamos a tener mil millones de
pesos 2 mil millones de pesos 3 mil
millones de pesos 4 mil y 5 mil millones
de pesos así que primero pensemos en la
curva de la demanda y que al final es
una curva del beneficio que vamos a
obtener económicamente hablando desde
que tú pides un préstamo bancario aunque
sea por al menos unos pocos pesos
debes de ver a alguien que ya va a
sacarle provecho a ello porque te va a
prestar este dinero con una cierta tasa
de interés lo que quiere decir es que
entre más dinero pidas prestado pues más
feliz vas a hacer a la persona que te lo
presta sin embargo las cosas son más o
menos así entre menos cantidad de dinero
te presten la tasa de interés va a ser
más grande y entre más cantidad de
dinero te presten la tasa de interés va
a ser más
esto quiere decir que si tú pides muy
poco dinero por lo tanto datacenter es
va a estar cercana al 30% y entonces la
curva de la demanda se vería más o menos
así va a bajar del 30% y entre más
dinero menos tasa de interés y es que
suena lógico no es el mismo riesgo que
te presten una cantidad de dinero
pequeña a que te presten una cantidad de
dinero muy grande por lo tanto nuestra
curva de la demanda se va a ver más o
menos así y es justo esta misma curva a
la que se ve cuando hablamos cerca de la
renta de un departamento es la renta de
cualquier artículo que se te pueda
ocurrir pero bueno ahora vamos a pensar
también en la curva de la oferta y cómo
se va a ver nuestra curva de la oferta y
bueno cuando pensamos en la curva de la
oferta pues ésta va a tener la misma
forma que tiene la curva de la oferta de
cualquier producto así que para los
primeros pocos pesos la gente que presta
dinero estoy imaginando la gente que tal
vez no tenga nada que hacer con el
dinero y por lo tanto su costo marginal
de prestar su dinero es muy pequeño y
por lo tanto tiene una pequeña tasa de
interés y empezará por aquí
es decir si la gente está dispuesta a
prestar su dinero a una tasa interés
pequeña no sé cercana al 1% y después si
la deuda empieza a crecer peso a peso la
tasa de interés aumentará cada vez más y
entonces la tasa de interés por el
siguiente peso será cada vez mayor dando
esta gráfica a la curva de la oferta con
esto ya tenemos la curva de la oferta y
la demanda del mercado para prestar
dinero durante un año
y ojo esta cantidad está dada en miles
de millones de pesos por año entonces
por año es decir cuánto dinero te van a
prestar en un año o en dado caso cuánto
dinero va a prestar durante un año y
bueno ahora que ya tenemos la curva de
la demanda y la curva de la oferta
entonces tenemos nuestro punto de
equilibrio aquí el cual va a tener una
cierta cantidad y un cierto precio
entonces voy a pintarlo aquí y tenemos
un cierto precio como es eso recuerda es
la tasa del interés es decir tenemos una
cierta tasa de interés en este punto de
equilibrio la cual va a ser igual a 10%
de otra manera 10 centavos por peso por
cada año mientras que si ahora vemos
cuál es la cantidad de equilibrio nos
vamos a dar cuenta que está cercano al
2.7 2.8 miles de millones de pesos por
año así que vamos a empezar a pensar
todo esto pero en el sentido
macroeconómico cómo podemos darle un
sentido o una orientación macroeconómica
imagínate que empezamos a prestar dinero
y cómo va a cambiar este estado este
país como a cambiar el mundo si todos
tuviéramos más dinero en nuestra bolsa
imagínate que el gobierno y las personas
que están en la presidencia se suben
helicópteros y empiezan a aventar dinero
hacia todas las personas que hay en el
mundo bueno pues esto lo que va a hacer
es que la oferta se vaya hacia arriba
repentinamente la gráfica de la oferta
se va a recorrer hacia derecha porque va
a aumentar la oferta porque hay más
gente con más dinero que va a querer
prestar dinero y entonces ahora tenemos
una nueva curva de la oferta que se ve
más o menos así y también lo que va a
pasar es que la demanda
porque la gente como ya tiene más dinero
pues entonces menos gente va a querer
pues pedir un préstamo por lo tanto la
curva de la demanda lo que va a pasar es
que va a disminuir la gente que
necesitaba el dinero pues ahora necesita
menos dinero y por lo tanto la curva de
la demanda se va a recorrer hacia la
izquierda ahora tenemos un nuevo punto
de equilibrio si te das cuenta y bueno
este nuevo punto de equilibrio va a
depender bastante de cuánto yo mueva una
gráfica a la otra pero lo primero que
quiero que te des cuenta es que la
cantidad de equilibrio no cambia mucho
sin embargo nuestro precio de equilibrio
ese fue el que se fue hacia abajo es
decir nuestra tasa de interés de
equilibrio ha disminuido vamos a suponer
que se fue al 6% y sonaba lógico ahora
imagínate el caso contrario que es lo
que va a pasar si por algún motivo no se
desaparece el dinero o no sé la gente va
a querer prestar menos dinero bueno pues
por lo tanto va a cambiar también
nuestro punto de equilibrio sería bueno
que tú te imaginarás qué es lo que va a
pasar en un contexto macroeconómico
acerca de esta situación en el caso en
el que la gente no va a querer prestar
en esta ocasión nada
y el dinero va a escasear